i have been focused on eating
healthfully
the last few years i really have and one
important component of a healthy diet
is fiber fiber is cool and adding more
of it into your daily routine can start
first thing in the morning with
breakfast
and here to teach us all about fiber is
best-selling author
and nutritionist joy bauer hi joy
such a treat to be here and thank you
for this cozy attire
well you know joy and i got in our pjs
um
because we're like working with the
coolest brand ever kelloggs
and i actually go way back with this
brand
um i did a commercial for kellogg's rice
krispies when i was five years old
look there you go how it started and 42
years later
how it's going i understand yeah i know
and i this is like a really authentic
thing for me because
i love i'm eating frosted mini wheats
hashtag fmws
and when i got my first apartment this
was like what was in my cupboard
i loved and i thought i sounded cool
being like i'm just having my fmws this
morning
and i've really lived my whole life with
the kellogg's
family as a consumer or someone who was
in their commercials and here i am again
full circle and for me cereal is it
how come i didn't get a bowl oh my god
i'm actually going to give you would you
like raisin bran or fmw's
uh raisin bran perfect we're gonna
spread it out
that's really nice um thank you
well it's not the prettiest poor joy
sorry about that
um how do you feel about almond milk
love it okay good here you go love it
and then i have a spoon for you hold on
let me open that over
there you go all right so kellogg's
frosted mini wheats and kellogg's raisin
bran are both
high in fiber and a good source of
different vitamins and minerals but
joy i really want to throw it to you and
ask what is fiber and what is its
function what's the power of fiber so
fiber is an indigestible nutrient that
helps to
enhance digestive health and there's two
different types of fiber there's
insoluble
and soluble fiber and you don't really
need to memorize the differences all you
do need to know is that they're both
really good for you and they're found in
plant-based foods
fruits vegetables nut seeds and whole
grains
okay why do you think that people maybe
don't get
enough fiber well first because they
just don't eat a whole lot of healthful
foods remember that fibers found
in plant-based foods we need to eat more
vegetables
more fruit more whole grains nuts and
seeds
i think another big problem is that a
lot of people are carb phobic now
they're afraid of carbohydrates now
there are
better carbohydrates high quality
carbohydrates that
nobody should be afraid of and again
it's all of those great vegetables and
the fruit salads and the whole grains
like these things are really good for us
it makes me sad when people are afraid
of carbs
the better carbs right right right um
well everyone says that you need more
water and if you're eating a lot of
fiber then how much water should we be
drinking i'm so
glad that you bought that up because you
do need ample amounts of water
when you're taking in more fiber and
everybody needs to eat more fiber
so here's what you need to know take
your weight
and then divide it in half that is the
amount of water you need to aim for
every single day so you take your weight
divide it in half and that's the amount
of water
ounces and also keep in mind that if you
exercise a lot so you're continuously
sweating or you live in a very hot
climate
you need even more water but the good
news is it's flat water
and carbonated sparkling water and
coffee and tea
it all yeah counts
then i'm pickled with iced tea it's
perfect
i've always had a theory that it's like
preserving me because i drink
eight to ten glasses of that a day so
you're getting your water
um okay you're gonna put our fiber
knowledge to the test joy in a
did you know challenge called the finer
facts of fiber
[Music]
and here's how it's going to work joy is
going to read out some facts and myself
and our vfs and crew have to use our
paddles
to guess if it's true or false
and because kellogg's is sold at walmart
for every answer i get correct one of
our vffs will get a 100
walmart gift card all right oh gosh
pressure's on
okay i want to deliver for you guys all
right joy i'm ready okay here we go the
first question true or false
fiber has its own taste
you would get it right and so the answer
is false
fiber does not have a taste fiber does
have a texture personality
and that's a good thing all right good
deal you're one for one
true or false fiber is only found
naturally in plants
[Applause]
so the operative word here is naturally
fiber is only naturally found
in fruits vegetables nuts seeds and
whole grains
sometimes you'll see it in things like
protein powders or beverages
but it's not naturally occurring
companies are
adding synthetic fiber into that you're
doing
really well thank you joy well this
conversation
definitely prepped me wow i will say
that
true or false fiber helps you feel
full true
oh my gosh this is for you oh look at
you guys all know
wow well here's the deal with fiber so
fiber
takes up space in your stomach so it
helps you feel
full okay so now question four
true or false a breakfast of scrambled
eggs with two slices of
whole grain toast provides more fiber
than a bowl of whole grain cereal with
milk and berries
fall
[Applause]
wow so this was a little bit of a trick
question because the eggs don't have any
fiber at all it's a protein food
the whole grain toast each slice will
provide about two to three
grams of fiber but when you compare it
to a bowl of cereal
the whole grain high fiber cereal will
bring about six grams to the table
then we're topping it with berries so
you get a double hit of fiber
the cereal with the berries wins cereal
with the berries wins
okay joy one last one last here we go
true or
false young people don't have to worry
about eating as much fiber oh come on
that one's easy
and false would be the answer you guys
we answered all five questions correctly
and guess what all of our vffs you're
gonna go
home with a hundred dollar gift card
from walmart
i know i love it
and to celebrate our partnership with
kellogg's frosted mini wheats and
kellogg's raisin bran
they are going to donate 25 000
to no kid hungry i know
and that means that hungry children in
america will get up to 250
000 meals thank you kelloggs thank you
so much for that
and um i just want to thank our vff's
for playing along so well
i want to thank kellogg's for their
donation to no kid hungry
and i want to thank joy for bringing joy
and health and
like intelligence to our kitchen and our
bodies and our lives
oh well thank you i just i love the show
i love you and
i feel like i'm paroled this is my first
day out
and look you're rocking the pjs you got
the marabou on the feet
you